you thought you a perfect so that means
I might be the whole wall yeah let's go
only for only for that one big save huge
save softener shop big turnover
nine years ago eight years ago I start a
company with my brother called
vaynermedia with one agenda which was in
Star Wars terms to build a
communications Death Star to be able to
point to anything that I want to do for
the next 30 years I'm very interested
thank you yeah yeah but but a macro very
ambitious and in a micro an amazing
amount of patience like building a
client service business over the last
eight years is not necessarily like what
a lot of my friends think I should be
spending my wasting my time on but I
understand why I'm doing it
big companies are really bad at math and
small companies are really bad at art
you know the big brands want to spend
two million dollars on making a video
and using Nielsen ratings and their
opinions and the small companies think
it's all math and that's why they end up
running at a time because CAC an LTV are
fine
but when you're not actually building
brand you become unbelievably vulnerable
to whatever platform you're doing your
CAC and LTV on so we've you know by
creating that friction of the two
disciplines we've been able to build
something and it's starting to really
resonate so we've been growing very
quickly in the last two years I think at
first people were trying to figure out
what we were doing or we were coming
from such a different angle you know
back to the early days where you and I
met like all that talk was unheard of
for Madison Avenue you know Pepsi and
Unilever were they they were like
where's your can lions it's why within
our organization I've done such a big
push for voice one I believe in it but -
I needed 850 people - remember we're
trading attention not social media I
didn't want our company to become what I
make fun of which is you become so
religious about what got you there they
you know I was very important for the
company not to think of ourselves as
social media because if I started the
company eight years earlier when I
doing the wine business we would have
been Google search and email to me it's
whatever the arbitrage is you know and
then understanding when things get too
expensive not expensive enough and just
looking at it all agnostic Lee even my
content you know why you're nineteen old
son thinks it's cool it's I don't even
think about content without thinking
about distribution I don't ever think
about content without the context of the
platform and most of all I never think
about content unless I think about the
empathy for the end users consuming it
you're saying I brought the greatest
weather Helsinki in the history Finnish
summer is short how what are the hours
that it's light out it was so light ever
no no but right now it's just never dark
awesome hello how are you so nice to
meet you best mistake a company can make
in online marketing there's so many
mistakes I think one of the biggest
mistakes they can make is they fall in
love with the math too many people
thought my marketing are not doing
marketing they're doing sales so
everything is so predicated on last
touch attribution you know customer
acquisition cost it's just math math
math this Google ad cost 19 cents to get
somebody here and that's better than 22
cents on Facebook or 39 cents on
snapchat and they leave it very basic
they only look at the math and so the
number one mistake in 2018 that I see is
an addiction to just math without
putting brand or marketing or the
long-term impacts of becoming only a
math based marketer or even scarier
using vanity metrics like impressions or
likes as a proxy to the success of their
business or the cost of the seat
I see so many people buying programmatic
banner ads because it's $5 CPM but not a
soul on earth none of you actually see
it so math and then the worst version of
it is math that doesn't matter I think
you start with content from people like
me that's why I do it I think the only
way a person changes their mind is by
hearing a different perspective and so
maybe I resume for some people I don't I
don't need it to be me I need to be
somebody like me you have to hear
alternatives and positivity too many
people were raised to be insecure to
follow the system and I'm very
passionate you know to break through
through a different style you know I've
got my aggressive style and I think
other people have passive styles and
whatever works but you've got to hear it
a different way look at this the odds of
you existing are the same as 2 million
people rolling a trillion sided dice and
all landing on the same number doesn't
mean to and I it's about perspective
yeah you know I'm just about perspective
absolutely coming thank you thank you
Finland is one of the most interesting
markets in the world for somebody like
me because I'm unemotional meaning
marketing to me is just you know whether
it's outdoor or or Google or Facebook or
snapchat or Instagram or drawing on a
building or a flyer or television I'm
just unemotional I don't care I don't
love digital I don't like technology I
like attention because if you have
attention then you can tell somebody
what you're about Gary okay okay what
happens
[Music]
these guys don't you old and strong yes
yeah yeah let's sit down just gonna grab
a coffee yeah yeah that's what I think
the new world's about you know I when
you look at wrestling WWF or WWE or
tennis when it had broadcasting on
network sport uh here's a perfect
example in 1947 in America horse-racing
boxing and baseball number one two and
three right baseball number one because
the radio was distributing baseball
horse-racing and boxing I think if you
actually own a league like this you can
go make a deal with snapchat or Twitter
or Facebook for distribution you might
be it you might really be able to do
something I guess where I'm going with
this as we're wrapping up I think the
next frontier for product companies is
to become a media company instead of
advertising which is renting you guys
have the money and now the distribution
is I mean look I'm filming a vlog this
is you know I'm doing reality television
on YouTube and Facebook you I think
there's something very interesting and
taking your assets and and I mean
YouTube and Facebook needs content it's
like the old ESPN remember you had a
fill it with something there's something
to think about
are you filming your speeches you should
yeah get somebody to film them and post
them on Facebook and LinkedIn it's a
very good point
do it yeah let it travel outside the
four walls yeah to your point put a flag
in the ground yeah I think I think you
can I think there'll be some room to
play you weren't you weren't good at a
paper paper you weren't good at paper
football season really goes hold on now
I'm getting competitive that was good
yeah you ever play this you remember
this that was a touchdown Dirac and then
and then I like you you know like ice to
beat like honestly in eighth grade in
eighth grade I went 48th and one and
when Ian Heffernan beat me in paper
football I lost my [ __ ] like complete
like got detention for a month because I
like rampage the whole like remember
have fun that was
[Music]
about him
yeah doing video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
guys
[Music]
period
super rad I feel like a nice finished
boy
[Music]
when we go here what is that it's really
cool I need to plan to retake it yes and
because of me I have this optical
illusion do you see it's impossible yes
so you'd be sitting in the V and there
could be more of these bees I think the
answer right now to everything is more
yeah you know everyone's like what
should I do for my personal rather like
as much as possible if you can do a
daily podcast yes if you can do a vlog
yes if you can post five times a day on
Instagram yes if you can do 30 s posts
for stories for Instagram and snapchat
yes if you can reply to 50 people on
Twitter yeah like to me the answer is
yes and so what the blog does it opened
up everything else now I don't I
document I don't create right so even
this clip even this is very meta because
now it might be titled for Facebook like
how somebody should be thinking about
building out their team friend here it
is I don't have to sit and write you
know what I mean hey everybody I'm Gary
Vaynerchuk thanks for coming out tonight
I've got to say hello to a bunch of you
but the ones that came in a little later
I'm looking forward to saying hello in a
little bit we're gonna film an
askgaryvee show for me the number one
rule that everybody here should think
about whether you're building a personal
brand or a business is not to create
friction for the audience so if they
want to watch my vlog on Facebook I'm
gonna give it to them if they want to
watch it on YouTube I'm gonna give it to
them if they want to listen to it on a
podcast I'm gonna give it to them I
think the biggest mistake people here
make and when I say here I mean [ __ ]
everyone is they make content for them
and their behaviors not for everybody
else's
I think for example a lot of these video
stars better started getting real
serious about audio because video is
going to be on decline because video
takes time
I'll take you guys out to dinner you and
the winner he'll have a nice time then
my my office is literally my office -
Madison Square Garden is like from here
to the second white that first one small
white building like you're going down on
30th and 10 ok it's a new project it
used to be the railroads now it's Hudson
you it's called Hudson Yards they used
to be old railroad tracks the old pencil
Econoline so literally ranked Iraq we
think like from here - like that's
correct
and they were gonna build the Jets and
Giants Stadium the Jets stadium their
original so that's where our office is
some right there ok all right
I'm good right I'm gonna say hello a
couple more people but I'm gonna try to
get some rest
what time is tomorrow yeah
[Music]
[Music]